das spiel zwischen dem vfl bochum und
den bayern sorgt für die überraschung
des spieltages zwar trifft lewandowski
zum 1 0 für die münchner die jedoch
anschließend ihre grundordnung und die
orientierung verlieren der bald
dortmunder süden in der mitte mit zu
viel abstand hand wie ag1
zwangsausgleich keine 15 minuten
gespielt ob amerikaners run spiel der
nächste bayern lapsus luca die eiskalt
vom punkt 21 punkten nur zwei minuten
später der vfl zaubert gabor
künstlerisch wertvoll um reich der neue
vertreter machtlos 3 zu 1 für den
aufsteiger
nach 40 minuten
kurz vor der pause holtmann genial 41
bochum vier gegentore vor der pause
kassierte der rekordmeister zuletzt
1975 da war der aktuelle bayern trainer
nagelsmann noch nicht auf der welt in
der zweiten hälfte verkürzt lewandowski
noch artistisch für mehr reicht es
jedoch nicht der tabellenführer verliert
24 in bochum unter vfl feiert den ersten
sieg gegen die münchner nach 18 jahren
nach dem münchner ausrutscher kann
dortmund mit einem sieg bei union berlin
den abstand in der tabelle verkürzen die
voraussetzungen nicht ideal an der alten
försterei hat der bvb bislang nur
verloren doch an diesem spieltag läuft
es marco reus in der 18 minute zum 1 0
der bvb nach der jüngsten pleite gegen
leverkusen auf wiedergutmachungs kurs
und die klar bessere mannschaft wieder
raus 20 dortmund nur sieben minuten
später für union ist es ein gebrauchter
nachmittag geräte erhöht in der 71 auch
3 zu 0 für die borussia die eisernen
treffen zwar noch durch gewalt jedoch
wird das tor wegen eines vorangegangenen
fouls von julia anna kanji
zurückgenommen
es bleibt beim 13 0 borussia dortmund
feiert einen historischen sieg es ist
der erste dreh an der alten försterei
und ist ein sechs punkte hinter bayern
das mainzer gastspiel in freiburg sorgt
für den aufreger des spieltages bei den
schiedsrichter deniz aytekin im fokus
steht in der 31 minute erzielt alexander
hug das 1 0 für die nullfünfer es ist
die umstrittene szene der video
assistent überprüft ein mögliches
handspiel von hug dabei ist es die
abseitsstellung des mainzers bei kurs
kopfball zuspiel und durch fleckens
parade entsteht keine neue
spielsituation das tor zählt
fälschlicherweise und der schiedsrichter
entschuldigt sich nach dem spiel für
seinen fehler
unumstritten ist in der zweiten hälfte
nach einer grätsche ecke das tor von
peter sind zum verdienten freiburger
ausgleich in der 69 minute eins zu eins
am ende unter dem strich eine
punkteteilung mit bayrischen
duell der gegensätze leverkusen die
beste rückrunden mannschaft empfängt mit
dem vfb die schwächste mannschaft der
rückserie war er mit einer starken
ersten hälfte die awi zum 1 0 für die
werkself kurz vor der pause nach dem
seitenwechsel trifft stuttgarts
winter-neuzugang tiago thomas zum 1
1-ausgleich in der 49 minute nur drei
zeigerumdrehungen später die
leverkusener antwort die mir bei
freistoß auf 3 2 zu 1 bei
die wilde schlussphase florian würz erst
trocken zum 3 1 in der 86 doch die gäste
antworten
thiago thomas staubt in der 88 minute ab
nur noch 23 doch auf der gegenseite
macht patrick in der 90 minute alles
klar 4 2-endstand in leverkusen
unterstreicht seine
champions-league-ambitionen stuttgart
weiter tief im keller
köln zu gast in leipzig das duell um die
europacupplätze bongartz team in der
tabelle vor den sachsen das highlight
des abends in der 25 minute kroos
freistoß kunst zum 10
der diskus leipziger insgesamt die
bessere mannschaft die in der zweiten
hälfte durch olmo in der 54 minute auf 2
0 erhöht nur drei minuten später legte
soldo auf und ein cellino vollendet zum
13 0 für rb der fc überfordert in der
nachspielzeit noch kölner
ergebniskosmetik durch lemperle mehr
gelingt nicht leipzig gewinnen mit 3 zu
1 gegen köln und überholt baumgarts fc
in der tabelle
[Musik]
eintracht frankfurt gegen wolfsburg die
niedersachsen mit dem zurückgekehrten
max kruse feierten zuletzt gegen fürth
einen wichtigen sieg im abstiegskampf
nach videobeweis gibt es elfmeter für
wolfsburg kruse tritt an und trifft in
der 28 zum 1 0 für die gäste sein erstes
tor für wolfsburg nach seiner rückkehr
in der nachspielzeit die entscheidung
lücke baku aus spitzen winkel 2 0 für
den vfl nach zuvor elf sieglosen
pflichtspielen feiert wolfsburg den
zweiten dreier in serie und verschafft
sich luft im tabellenkeller
klar dass eintracht kassierte dagegen
die dritte heimniederlage nacheinander
stefan leiters für zu erwischen einen
traumstart gegen die hertha keine 30
sekunden gespielt da schon eins zu null
die zweite hälfte mittels der zahn spiel
elfmeter für die frankenhöhe gotha
eiskalt doppelpack 20 verführt 71
minuten gespielt die alte dame aus der
hauptstadt war zu spät auf der
17-jährigen gächter bringt die hertha in
der 82 minute noch mal ran doch es
reicht nicht mehr zwei zu eins am ende
shirt damit fünf heimspiele ungeschlagen
berlin im jahr 2022 weiter sieglos
nach zuletzt vier heimpleiten in serie
empfängt gladbach den fc augsburg in
einem packenden spiel geht die borussia
durch kunde je nach einer halben stunde
in führung
in der zweiten hälfte erhöhte hofmann
kurz nach dem seitenwechsel zum 2 0 für
hütters gladbacher die abstiegsbedrohten
augsburger kommen erst durch die ago in
der 55 minute ins spiel nur noch zwei zu
eins die antwort der fohlen nur zwölf
minuten später per kopf 3 zu 1 in der
nachspielzeit gelingt dem fch durch 5
version der anschlusstreffer doch zu
spät gladbach gewinnt mit 3 2 und
feierte den ersten heimsieg seit
november
der abschluss des spieltags hoffenheim
empfängt gut gelaunte bielefelder das
team von frank kramer seit sechs spielen
ungeschlagen die tsg von den jüngsten
vier pflichtspielniederlagen
unbeeindruckt und durch hübner in der 22
minute in führung
die zweite hälfte größer in der 51
minute auf 2 0 für die kraichgauer
gleichzeitig der endstand bielefeld
verliert mal wieder und kramers gute
laune ist dahin die ergebnisse des 22
spieltags im überblick bayern verliert
in bochum dortmund leipzig und
leverkusen holen jeweils drei punkte in
der tabelle verkürzte der bvb den
abstand auf spitzenreiter bayern leipzig
neuer vierter im tabellenkeller
augsburg punktgleich mit bielefeld vor
stuttgart und führt auf den
abstiegsplätzen
[Musik]